Oh God bird adjusting your seat I wasn't
ready
I um Dum Dum Dum Dum Dum Dum Dum Dum Dum
Dum Dum Dum Dum Dum Dum Dum Dum Dum did
I have a way out a lot of people like
this movie okay uh yeah yours you know
what everything that's wrong with this
movie can be summed up in four syllables
pg-13 you know let's talk about that
because that you know let's just jump
right in really cuz there's a lot wrong
with this movie outside of that but that
is a major component and I'll tell you
exactly why people so underestimate the
importance of the gore in this movie I
know that makes us sound like
Psychopaths they look at it this way if
you have a Psychopaths look at this way
if you were to watch an itchy and
scratchy cartoon and take out the gore
would it be as good if you took no pg-13
itchy and scratchy cartoon name right on
The Simpsons and turned it into a G
cartoon where Oh wha come on Marge
Simpson like lemonade bye Thank You
Scratchy yeah all they're doing to us
yeah what people forget is that you know
the the gore adding that much blood in
like an itchy and scratchy cartoon and
sort of this exploitative element to it
that's fun it's a tear cool and it's and
it's creative it's the same thing with
here mortal kombat really the game way
came out was very exploitative it is
vital be it doesn't make simply
vegetative and if that's not your thing
fair enough I get it but it taught me
that it taught me the fear all things
Chinese because all Chinese men just
want me to battle with someone else to
the dowser wrong we fatality
um and I furnish Sherman you know it's
kind of like going into a shaft and
being like you know why were they so
against whites that's just what it is
yes we make a voicing this is the movie
and you have pretty much like one guy
guys I think like in the hope they are
maybe two uh yeah it was I don't
remember what it was I just remember
leaving that cinema and thinking it was
a really low body count for something
called Mortal Kombat I should have been
seeing people just there should have
been bodies just falling from the sky
whenever it rained it should have been
raining bodies and blood
that's Mortal Kombat that's really as
what is I mean now world combat has gone
to a point where it's like the
fatalities are so over the top and so
crazy and so extreme that that's what
you look forward to that would make an
amazing Boop yeah and they don't do any
of it and granted back then I don't know
if they had like quite the quote-unquote
technology like what they can do in the
games like CG wise but you know what no
but you look out so lay the practical
effects like enable cop and total reboot
is up could have done it Oh
Robocop mates makes the Mortal Kombat
movie look like the freakin Care Bears I
mean like that that's the thing it's
Mortal Kombat and yet it is such a weak
looking movie like it's just it's a
pansy-ass movie like the hardly any
blood or gore or anything I will say
this actually we're talking about the
look of it the look it see this came out
very close to street fighters so
everyone's argument when it came out was
well at least it's not Street Fighter
and that's the sort of what that's like
Segal at least is under Ebola movie
that's bottom of the bear yeah no word
but I told you to agree but I will say
that the actual look at the film cuz
this was when the Super Mario Brothers
came out history fair none of these
movies based on games were looking like
the games at all this at least like
maybe fifty percent of it actually
looked like the game sub-zero looks like
sub-zero scorpion looks like scorpion
but then you got stuff like you know
Raven did not look like rated
I knew already that we were both going
to have some good laughs and be in big
trouble simultaneously when you know
Christopher Lambert first shows up with
the whole peasant like Asian peasant had
more than mighty hand I like it like
just does this like like he has the
weirdest look when he first shows up
he's like crossovers everything all
right now I'm like what the hell is this
that's like their one pointy hat ball
bed so I get there we he's kinda wearing
low and there's a war behind his
fantastic right voice here in a
challenge here in a game immortal camera
very quick talk hey-oh
you're captain fools I know it even
lights the old Elvis yeah it not in the
funny because I love Christopher Lambert
but like it's just one of those things
I'm like okay well I think he realizes
he's in a goofy movie when fuckin you
know the geeky know who almost like
almost Cowboys Aikido he's got alone too
much Aaron said by water looks and then
he fucking talk to everyone things like
you know everyone thinks I'm like
against the accent like there is owes
the figures eggs no making fun effect
that's a goofy fucking voice yeah okay I
mean like someone can say I have a weird
voice it's not my American accent Johnny
Johnny Cage was just insufferable Wow
walking I you know we just got done
watching a Fantastic Four and I mean
like he just makes Chris Evans and
Fantastic Four of a perfectly likable
like I'm like well I'll take the flaming
torch over Johnny Cage any day so that
surprised um anywho why what does it
matter what does it matter I guess
nothing cameras gonna post Irvine and
they're gonna figure it out anyway
better figure it out figure it out with
less Demi trip but anyway my numbers got
this an overweight Ozzie not that big a
deal with the anyway ah so it was just
like just I'm just saying when I saw
there with that
when I saw fantastic for the movie which
one when you said Chris Evans so yeah
yeah yeah the one with Chris Evans I
just remember thinking well at least
he's not his biggest Johnny Cage should
horn honk up what and now he's a
perfectly serviceable Captain America um
Luke a you just ran place with anyone
random Asian actor vaguely doing a Bruce
Lee bail is just there was nothing to
that character go Gora Gora at the time
wasn't impressive at act I think you
know the lips are still a little off but
it's like he's still present Elysa he's
actually there i given hoobie
credibility g in it home they could have
CG him as they did so i really go does
the shang soon from the game the old ass
crusty shang soon from the game come off
is more intimidating than this guy in
this movie like i was like i still the
old shang soon watching the match with
his leg he's intimidated yeah with this
in the game white eyes just is like more
scary than this guy in this killer get
one scary effect where he turns into the
skull that jump scare at the beginning
and i'm like well that's as scary as it
gets well and i think part of it is the
it's kind of a yoda effect to even
though it's like very old where you get
the you can just like move a finger and
you'd be like hurry that would explode
or something uh so you gotta head back
gonna kiss he would just sit at his
throne and that was hideo just like yeah
likes that guy gonna do i don't know
where he's the old like shaolin zen
master who's like all-powerful see he's
like the emperor yeah like you know from
Return of the Jedi like you just know
he's badass cuz he won't do anything cuz
he's like he's that bad I see that he
doesn't need to do anything oh and this
guy I mean he's got the martial arts and
everything you know what I look cool in
like the code or something but most
gracious like you know that's always
fine that's like you're trying way too
hard oh yeah eat more scenery
um I'm trying to think I just how do you
mess up Mortal Kombat
it looks like they was right any sick it
easily is a itself you know but like I
really I feel like I do have to give
some credit because it is not it's
nowhere near like anything like the
worst that we saw no there's been way
worse
that's the thing it's Mortal Kombat you
can say there's way worse but there
should have been way better out of
Mortal Kombat it's surprisingly I mean
you could have given me 12 people in
cage matches to the death that ended
with them all whipping their heads off
hearts out and bodies exploding I would
have been perfectly fine with that
they're like oh I didn't need a damn
plot I just needed violence it'd be not
easy
um but yeah and I think when I'm
watching this as like I'd saw this was
like maybe 14 or something like that
yeah I was 16 and can you imagine like
that's what it was it was like the
disappointment of being at just the
right age as a teenager boy this is
gonna be awesome of him being like
what's blechy 13 boy when I was younger
it was I was very half and half cuz like
I said I was a little optimistic cuz at
least like I said after the pain a
fucking Mario Brothers everybody fighter
I was like at least it looks like the
game and ELISA has something connecting
a little bit to the story uh but you
know but those were never the big
elements of Mortal Kombat the big game
Mortal Kombat it was was the gorse boy
tation it was the plus point a chinois
and you would have thought they would
have learned that after Street Fighter
that story maybe is not the strong suit
of these games yeah like maybe you
should bank on something else other than
story when Mortal Kombat tries to tell a
story it's painful not as painful as
Mortal Kombat annihilation but at least
I'd give that movie some credit
annihilation for being so batshit insane
it's like the room it's over like really
a jacket is a roommate is the room of
video game movies it's hilarious how bad
it is I can't even say it but mortal
comedy is just mad from 300 it gets old
it's a boring ass movie Mortal Kombat is
a boring movie
yeah and lease annihilation is
entertaining and how bad it is and crazy
and weird it's like this one it's like
starts off kind of interesting you set
up the characters they all kind of look
the part you know they're not all the
best actors
whatever they look the part sub-zero and
scorpion come in you know share they get
a fighter
usually the deadliest of enemies but see
how this is the movie and everyone wants
to see that we're not going to see that
now they're going to be together because
you want to focus more on you know Sonya
asking for help or Johnny Cage we're
about to be incontestable yeah that's
what we fucking want in a world I want a
birdie I wanted more scenes with Johnny
Cage
thank you you read my mind um and uh
yeah and then somewhere like even just
by dull movies they're bad movie
standards it just becomes really dull
because they kind of get to this place
you're getting used to this place yeah
looks kind of need for a bit and then
you kind of get tired of looking at it
and then Glaros there and he looks
pretty cool you kind of get tired of
looking at him and everything just
overstays its welcome
I like the sequel better in the way some
people kind of like Batman Robin cuz
it's so stupid at least it's got that
yeah no I much our watch the sequel
there but that's all I yeah I better
know it's actually so bad it's at least
entertaining it at least had the virtue
of being hilariously awful whereas
Mortal Kombat is is bad yeah it's a dull
film um and yet so many I still whenever
I mention that people how dare you like
Kay say that can he say you don't know
oh ok do you play the game I love it do
you know and I always look at it and
like people my age that's the funny
thing people my age are older like what
can be like I'm out of my mind I'm like
I'm sorry did you play the game don't
worry Fay I'm thinking did you play
because if you played it you'd realize
how terrible this movie
yeah I think it may be a big part of it
is that because like I said when I came
out of seeing the movie I I know is
pg-13 so I went and I was like yeah you
know my 14 year old mine's like it's
okay I went to ban whatever uh and I
think it's because like I said the video
game movies before it were just so
terrible and so not connected to the
game at all I was just happy to get even
like the tiniest drop
connecting to the game you know and I
did see some zero and scorpy on the big
screen I saw reptile you know on the big
screen you know that was kind of neat
you know I saw Liu Kang do it
I would kick you I saw them do the stuff
that I saw sometimes happen in Mortal
Kombat but not the really cool stuff I
wanted to see you know not so rated R so
we went from worst to just bad yeah yeah
like but I think I think that yeah
here's a ticket again that is the
different is part of it that's part of
it and the other thing is the intro I
just think the soundtrack probably less
is one of the best that that song is one
of the songs I it's like putting all
time that intro is like fucking crack
for your ears because I swear to God I
think what happened is people saw the
intro they got swept up in the credits
enough so and then and then rode that
high throughout the rest of the move see
that's what happened with me and Batman
forever cuz that Oh even though the
movies bad like that opening when you're
13 years old and you see these days
coming in this idea you big forever and
there's Batman doing his fucking as
there's a bit like you're free oh my god
I changed me oh yeah in Cisco was better
than the first bet no no I guess it was
right through the first yeah yeah no but
I was in no I superior than the last
whilst there that's to better than I was
he said it was either on but you said it
was as good or better than the first bed
I was in beautiful denial and I love me
tonight so gets on Mortal Kombat work I
think people just rode the high of their
let no enters of the song they got
played and danced clubs across the
country don't be yeah still being played
me and let me tell you just done there
guys I've been there that denial feel so
good it's incredible up that something
you're still feeling it for like so
start with your friends weary when I'm
just like yeah that movies no good
Mortal Kombat don't be like yeah but
great soundtrack yeah no tied up it's
every single person says it and I hear
the same thing about the matrix equals
even those that don't like a basically
losers like Jim has a phenomenal
soundtrack and I'm like hey that's great
I'll go buy the soundtrack I don't want
to watch the freaking blue can't just
skip the story and characters of dance I
like I'll blast that fucker in my car
like I did but yeah
I guess what made Smosh I made a good
soundtrack does not equal a good movie
sorry
equals a great soundtrack yes great
sound it's amazing sound don't really
does that equal equals slash through it
good movie yes like every time I see
this
Ian up a few times seen this movie like
uh you press play and as soon as you see
the new lysimeter I jump out a window
like the Plex and probably I think
that's what happened I think inside that
Mortal Kombat song are subliminal
messages or they release some sort of
toxic gas and put it up again it I gave
us a giant high and then it lasted all
the way through the end of the movie
that we love to like that was amazing
but then you watch it again like without
seeing the intro and all but you'd be
like huh oh yeah watch Mortal Kombat
without watching the opening credits and
tell me it's as good I'll bet you a
number of people do that bill is a born
baby by me but they play it like three
or four times in the movie and it's like
okay do this whenever they play that
song mute it and yeah be you know sex
fighting doesn't look you see but it's
like just lost Lomo booming guys
bargain-basement martial arts stuff is
that kind of bug me dude I kind of
expected more I kind of expected better
martial art but I guess because I'm like
well at least it's gonna have like
really kick-ass martial arts
choreography and I was like it was okay
like it wasn't bad but I still didn't
feel like this is like oh this sets a
standard like you watch any Jackie Chan
movie no mop the floor with it yeah umm
as I good example Jackie Chan's really
good but you know doesn't say like I
feel like I've seen better yeah you know
that when this film came out like I said
I would give credit that this was not at
the age yet where every action film had
to look good because that is the thing
now nothing's a bad thing at all but
every
film has to have a visual identity to it
in this one this is that time what it
didn't so I think those those tiny
little touches you know that it did look
like the game it was visually
interesting for the time uh you know and
it did have that soundtrack I think that
was enough for like a younger audience
really a pg-13 audience to go in and say
you know yeah that was great I like it I
got up I you know I played in a movie
this you know what it is I'm going to
get some target audience you've said it
best is pg-13 which yeah anywhere from
ages 7 through about like 18 like the
basically 7 to 13 basically is what I'm
thinking and I don't want a
motherfucking Mortal Kombat movie I can
take my kids to who wants that who guys
that heads oh sorry I really this movie
bothers me like I'm still bitter decades
later I can still feel the
disappointment crushing my heart like a
great fatality but hey it is I can see
Mortal Kombat wins bad movie yeah
disappointment this is why we're doing
so many fan films and stuff like this
because the original was just so good
and they know that just variations of it
are not going to be as good as that
original that they're like well let's
try to make a gory ingredient dark
anyway um you see where I'm going with
this
yeah so I mean I don't know what else
there is to say it's not like there was
much plot or anything and yeah I mean I
will say this the one thing that always
Christopher Lambert just cuz I think
he's the only one that realizes he's in
the band he uh um yeah god I try to
watch my team a tournament if there was
anyone else I was like I mean not all of
them are God annoying got awful annoyed
but it's really good though yeah trying
to think of anyone that was like that
that was an enjoyable performance to
watch all I'm on Sonya was amazing she
existed she powdered her lipstick where
is he you know what else I was gonna get
you too cuz okay it's not like Sonya was
did anyone pick Sony in the game nobody
did um you know but it's like you make
um one of the main characters I said
she's got the look she looks cool you
know the
we better Winter Games and making better
female character oh no in Catan oh yeah
Kisame it wasn't interesting looking so
me had nothing special no cool moves she
was where he was the token female
character yeah it's like alright put
something with breasts in a ponytail
it's pretty much all the thought that
went into Sonja's character yeah you
know like thought you know Johnny Cage
you know and uh
solve the CRO scorpion so yeah I mean
it's like the future games did wait no
no they think they got some character
killer fans and I get so good no
bullshit Oh monster power I don't know
they could draw the last year oh she's
like in the background like chained up
like you know what bad bad guys remember
that yeah yeah yeah so we got some good
chicks this video but no but what I was
gonna get to is that you know they all
have to learn something again I really
want fucking see them Mortal Kombat but
Sonia's big thing is that you know she
uh well Johnny Cage was you know don't
be an egotistical prick uh Liu Kang's
was like you know let go of the guilty
your brother or something like that hers
was not you remember more than that's
III could begin use Rob I just remember
hers was you don't learn to ask for help
because you know Ravens Ravens was avoid
highlighter to what was gonna say is
that cuz I make a big point about this
in the UH in the review is that she
succumbs to the dumbass and distressed
thing like she's totally capable and
kicked a be just don't lead done all
this shit and at the end just like uh
Shang stone comes in just puts her arm
behind her back she's like oh great ok I
told me
I guess like Jesus weren't you some sort
of like trained us than what wasn't
cheating us special something like that
yeah like it and like I'm just like wow
we suck no and like I thought that it's
like it's not like you know even if
you're gonna do that bullshit it's not
like she's like you know pitching today
I'm gonna she's gonna whale in her arms
sorry nice really like great broke the
bike but it's one of those things where
it's like and really your your big thing
that we're gonna build up here is that
you need to learn to answer help you
need to learn how to ask a guy to save
you and stuff and some yeah do we see
that much how many of these when you put
it like that you make it sound almost
sexist right so it's just one of those
nature it's a social justice warrior dug
out I think that that's the point demand
characters with brains how dare you but
that's the point where I think I was
starting to notice this stuff at least
in in the early night I think personally
I think stuff has gotten a lot better
there's still shit but it's gotten
better and but that was the point where
I starting to know it's like yet
something's up why are all these really
tough cool ladies like suddenly have to
be saved in the last third or headband
and someone else and that's why I was
trying to say like you know what's going
on here like don't disagree with you I'm
just amazed you put that much thought
into it like that would have required so
much thought in Mortal Kombat that I
didn't even register well I don't think
they're thinking it they're just like
you know oh well we again it's like the
Sony in the first game well we got the
chick to just I know she's not the main
main character me what what what boys
got a black we don't know you know so
well no chance repair covered that will
give her red hair will put her in a
yellow jumpsuit and will change your
name to April yeah god no be even April
I have personality that's what starting
to notice that I was always like a I
thank this movie for being kind of a
tipping point where I'm starting to say
okay what the what's going on yo the
other thing I'll say just like great
soundtrack
this was another bait and switch because
great trailer
yeah the trail isn't riding on the
subject but the trailer is legitimately
good and makes the movie look
way more serious and gritty than it ever
was and when they do the whole rundown
of names is that okay you're like yeah
so Dino so yeah yeah no no no answer
even yeah oh yeah I was like I'm excited
to see Sony at this probably know like
he knows - yeah yeah how many questions
and like and then when you hear Kino in
the movie I'm like oh like all of these
characters like look badass in the
trailer and then in the movie wait if
you have not seen that there's two
trailers that were like just gave us the
most dissapointing fills but the
trailers are still amazing uh it was
kind of like the Avengers trailer if
it's day cuz I just remember all of
these thirteen-year-old boys like in the
crowd we're all like yeah no I remember
that I remember boy it was like my god
they did it they finally did it we are
going to see more video game movie
that's actually the video game you know
we're I've also decided to film the top
of the mountain that is good
oh no no give me it was that and can I
get a new pair of jeans I may have just
just myself like the Mortal Kombat and
actually the Super Mario Brothers
triggered the original NASA I got the
power
not that GDS trailer goes everywhere
easily though because it davin out there
was it was warrior yeah but the original
Super Mario Brothers won that one kind
of was more like the kids were really
into it like but Mortal Kombat it was
like anybody between the ages of seven
and twenty five yeah was just yeah to
the millions oh man but no but those are
two trailers that if you just want to
see like fucking amazing trailers go see
the the Super Mario Brothers that opens
with uh the mother dropping off the kid
and then like you see Koopa in the rain
that's the one that's a great trailer
and then the Mortal Kombat really they
are both amazing and I like just watch
that a billion times as a buff to put on
these shitty ass watch that trailer and
then maybe you'll figure out why i would
be remised out
yeah like goes after cuz i every time i
see that trailer like occasion will rent
like a lot of um you see this one I'll
see the Mortal Kombat trailer
it's like man it's doing it again cuz
right now I'm just like I want to put a
mortal kombat and I was like now I'm
just gonna be disappointed it's stupid
trick it is amazing I can watch that
trailer forever so what have we
discovered Mortal Kombat one of the
greatest soundtracks ever and one of the
greatest trailers um not so much on the
movie no no that not very good movie but
I give it credit that um if you really
liked it liked it go ahead I'm not
saying you can't like I use underneath
where some of us come from those who
dare that because there are so many
other just those fucking chairs without
like mortal oh my god how is it possible
like I do like we existed 14 Mortal
Kombat we exist we live in your universe
we're gonna have to find a way to get
along that's all yeah you know we're
like mutants and I'm just saying if you
can learn to understand my viewpoint all
and understand yours I guess you like it
maybe you're a kid when you saw the
marriages like I just forget like Mortal
Kombat and the soundtrack is awesome not
okay cool
like and you know what from there maybe
we can finally achieve real peace did
you get a little dirty you will of clean
silver in between pg-13 Mortal Kombat
Doug take this review at Charlotte close
enough I'll end it there